il le ferait un grand plaisir de vous
accompagner dans cette réflexion
philosophique un peu culturelle sur les
valeurs universelles et universalisable
comme vous le savez que les bières la
terre devient de plus en plus un petit
village
le global devient locale le local
rentrer dans le global ici et ailleurs
on n'a plus les frontières nécessaire
pour discerner où est l'originalité de
notre culture
où est la spécificité de notre culture
et comment on pourrait défendre le
particularisme identitaire à un moment
où les valeurs deviennent de plus en
plus soit universalisable soit tout à
fait le contraire réfractaires à
l'universel réfractaires à être dans ce
sillage de la mondialisation qui est à
la fois
photo mh c'est à dire une certaine
fatalité puisque cette mondialisation
nous accompagne sur annie une exigence
de l'universel à l'eau si la
mondialisation fait véhiculer à la fois
la capitalisation du monde à la fois des
nouvelles valeurs
alala à la fois qui fait tomber des
frontières qu'ils soient étatiques aux
autres et à la fois certainement
l'universel s'impose sur nos pourquoi
pour accompagner cet homo mondialiste
qui est en émergence et qui est en
émergence en accéléré mêmes et le
pourquoi des choses parce qu'on en a
besoin maintenant de plus en plus des
valeurs communes
minimalement commune et il sait pas
nécessairement d'être commune au sens en
abstraction ou vides de sens
aimez vous les uns les autres la
solidarité internationale
mais plus que ça on a besoin de mettre
de la chair sur l'os de ces valeurs
communes pour pouvoir répondre à
l'exigence de l'universel est une des
exigences de l'universel dans les navan
c'est de ne pas tomber dans les dérives
de l'ethnocentrisme dans les dérives
surtout de
là je l'appelle la condescendance
raciale le contre les autres ou se
fermer se replier sur soi-même et
devenir presque dans un verrouillage
identitaire un verrouillage culturel
donc pratiquement cette diversité de
cultures n'est pas contestée personne ne
conteste le pluralisme religieux ou le
pluralisme de l'aider échelle des
valeurs au tout à fait le contraire on
veut les garder mais on veut les garder
ouvertes est allé chercher dans le génie
de chaque culture
le génie de chaque religion pratiquement
à respecter sa singularité mais surtout
ouvrir le monde sur plus plutôt un monde
un espace plus humain plus solidaire
mais quand même aussi qui permet de
garder l'inter échangé bilité garder la
coopération garder le flux dans l'espace
humain l'espace globale comme on le dit
alors la première peut-être indications
qui va nous aider de rendre toutes nos
valeurs
même si elles sont patrimoniale au
patriarcat loup nationale les rendent
les plus universalisable le premier
adage sois toi même comme un autre et
sur ce point
l'humanité elle n'est plus un moyen et
n'est plus un instrument pour combattre
d'autres humanité mais au contraire on
cherche une convergence des valeurs pour
consolider la démocratie dans laquelle
nous vivons ici particulièrement au
québec au canada
cette convergence va nous aider à être
ouvert à l'humanisme et attirer des
autres cultures à converger avec eux
être la main dans la main dans cette
démarche vers une démocratisation du
monde vers un humanisme libéral et sur
ce point les peut-être les valeurs qui
sont les plus importantes qu'il faut
travailler qu'il faut certainement
nourrir en eau et en chaque culture
ici et là dans le monde c'est le primat
de l'individu ce primat de l'individu
est très nécessaire pour que nous ne
soyons pas englouti dans un
communautarisme ou dans un tribalisme ou
dans un clanisme et en ce sens
l'individu devient prima mais sans que
la société soit atomisé sans que la nes
société soit un ensemble d'égocentrisme
tout à fait le contraire respecter
l'individu et surtout respecter le
primat de la liberté de conscience et la
liberté d'expression il ya une
différence
on peut être libre dans l'expression
dans la pensée mais pas nécessairement
être respectés dans notre liberté de
conscience la liberté de conscience
devient la valeur qui devrait et qui y
est de plus en plus universalisable en
ce sens que cette liberté de conscience
va nous permettre à objecter objecté et
contesté qu'il soit le despotisme
l'autoritarisme qu'il soit le fanatisme
l'obscurantisme et en ce sens la liberté
de croire et de ne pas croire être
respecté dans son for intérieur de ce
que l'on croit ou ne croient pas et met
à sol peut être limites sur ce point
comment traiter les échelles des
modalités différentes
surtout les modalités religieuse et
accepter que ces valeurs religieuses
soient aussi interpréter et réinterprété
vu leurs policiers me veulent vu leur
caractère équivoque qu'il soit
interprété pour aller sa cheminée dans
l'espace public ou si vous voulez
l'espace étatiques ou l'espace
international ou dans l'ordre mondial
qui est en cours quels sont les points
les plus importants à mon sens et je
serai sélectif sur ces points là
premièrement il faut dépasser la
tolérance la tolérance est acceptée la
tolérance est quelque chose qui est
vertueux et il faut certainement être
tolérant là à l'égard de l'autre mais la
tolérance même dans une démocratie
tolérance à l'égard de l'intolérance
aussi devrait être de mise
et c'est un principe de base mais les
intolérants ne devrait pas être toléré
jusqu'à une limite où il loue fait
effondrer la culture de la tolérance et
pour ne pas provoquer l'effondrement de
la culture de la tolérance
on a besoin d'une gestion et quand même
d'un ordinateur d'un état d'un peut-être
un système qui nous permet à la fois
d'être libres d'être démocratique et
d'être tolérant c'est celui de l'état de
droit où l'état laïc
qu'est ce que la laïcité ici c'est pas
la laïcité de la société
il faut faire la différence il n'y a pas
nécessairement une société laïque il y a
toujours une société plurielle plus
religieuse plus relais communautaires
pluriculturelle mais l'état lui devrait
être neutre et en ce sens être non pas
un état clérical non plus un état
religieux
mais ouvrir de la laïcité pour qu'elle
devienne pape plus qu'une gestion de
pluralisme une gestion non violente du
pluralisme religieux et elle devient en
ce sens n'ont pas une idéologie n'ont
pas à le dogme mais simplement une
technicalité de gestion de pluralisme
l'autre idée qui est importante pour que
nous soyons dans un espace universel
humain et solidaire et respectueux l'un
de l'autre
non pas simplement de s'arrêter au
niveau de l'égalité humaine qui est
l'égalité dans la dignité humaine qui
est quand même la base de toutes les
religions de toutes les grandes visions
du monde les grands récits et
biologiques du monde quand même
mais plus dans l'égalité citoyenne plus
sans minimiser l'importance de l'égalité
humaine mais être traité dans notre
espace dans l'égalité citoyenne et en ce
sens l'égalité citoyenne accompagne la
liberté citoyenne accompagne aussi
l'état de droit et devient un fondement
assez important dans notre façon de
regarder l'autre et à ce moment il
devient plus partenaires n'ont pas
simplement au niveau humain
mais il devient dans ses valeurs
citoyennes en ce sens ces valeurs
deviennent de plus en plus
universalisable et en ce sens les
valeurs universalisable deviennent à
l'intérieur d'un état d'une société qui
une couveuse pratiquement pour les
accompagner à la maturité pour
accompagner ce qu'on disait au début
l'homme aux mondialistes ou l'homme qui
devient de plus en plus lui-même
universel
alors comment réfléchir de la démocratie
et si j ici il faut se permettre une
critique c'est vrai que la démocratie en
tant que régime en tant que gestion de
l'espace pourraient souffrir de quelques
lacunes pourraient avoir des
performances plus ou moins négative à
quelques moments mais la démocratie
comme idéal
l'idéal libéral dans la démocratie reste
de plus en plus sans alternative et y
restent de plus en plus quand même la
voile la plus assurée pour nous pour
éviter les guerres fratricides les
guerre sectaire ou ce qu'on appelle le
choc des civilisations où les chocs des
religions en ce sens cette idiologie
confrontation elle de civilisation qui
est en cours aujourd'hui et qui
accompagne et les valeurs universelles
ou les valeurs universalisable c'est
notre choix
notre choix de peau de les éviter il
faut que l'humanité convergent vers des
nouvelles valeurs pour justement relever
les défis de la violence
cette violence de plus en plus nihiliste
apocalyptique qu'on la voit qui est auto
destructrice non pas simplement pour
celui qui atteint par cette violence
mais même pour celui qui fait usage de
cette violence parce que cette violence
et les nihilistes et elle devient auto
destructrice pour les cultures qui
l'incitent ou qui la justifient ou
qu'ils encouragent et en ce sens la
quête de la vérité
la quête de la vérité
vient un fondement important de l'humain
elle devient une aspiration
incontournable pour chaque être humain
pour pouvoir justement aller de plus en
plus vers un monde où on peut avoir des
valeurs communes
minimalement universel sans qu'elle soit
abstraite sans qu'elle soit vide de sens
mais applicable applicable dans les
entités politiques applicables dans
l'économie applicable dans le social
applicable
justement dans notre ordre culturel et
en ce sens le pluralisme des religions
et des morales il va être toujours là
mais on a besoin d'une harmonisation et
sur ce point il nous faut des réformes
doctrinal dans les religions qu'il soit
des réformes au niveau de l'éthique et
que les tic devient certainement plus
respectueuse de l'individu plus
respectueuse des patrimoines plus
respectueuse des cultures diverses mais
il faut converger avec l'exigence de
l'universel pour les amener tout à nous
accompagner accompagner les générations
futures la relève justement
générationnel qui va venir et qui va
avoir à vivre le moment instantanée que
aujourd'hui on est en train de vivre
dans l'informatique à un moment où
l'autre n'est plus celui qui suggère des
soupçons ou d'inquiétude au mélancolie
mais l'autre qui va devenir un
partenaire dans l'établissement de cet
ordre global de cette arche dorée
internationale de cette culture humaine
et en ce sens pour terminer la
démocratie va l'espé fondements majeurs
la démocratie et les plus naturelles de
ce qu'on le croit parce que la
démocratie va nous aider à nous et comme
être humain à faire notre propre auto
création à nous rendre de plus en plus
des êtres qui sont capables
d'accompagner les nouveautés les
nouveautés technologiques les nouveautés
et les
innovations scientifiques et autres et
sur ce point la démocratie c'est elle
qui va nous permettre un espace libéral
un espace d'harmonie et la démocratie va
nous accompagner à sortir vers la paix
perpétuelle et ce n'est pas une idée
naïve la paix perpétuelle
c'est une idée possible c'est un rêve
qui est quand même qui a sa
justification qui a ses fondements
même si il apparaît pour nous un peu non
pas à la portée de nos mains mais il
faut comprendre aussi que il est un
projet réalisable et c'est pas quelque
chose qui n'est pas dû à nous en tant
qu'être humain mais et c'est la seule
condition de vivre une humanité libre
juste et solidaire dans une fraternité
humaine
je vous remercie bien je vous salue bien
bas